verrons-nous l'automobile détrôné par le
cheval c'est peu probable et pourtant la
plus noble conquête de l'homme retrouve
une place privilégiée dans le domaine
des loisirs le limousin jouer la carte
du tourisme équestre avec sérieux atouts
la douceur du climat de grands espaces
des sites épargné par les exigences du
monde moderne
sans oublier la gastronomie et les
témoignages de son passé désormais il
vous est possible de découvrir cette
province en calèche cette nouvelle
formule de tourisme équestre vient
d'être expérimentée sur le plateau de
millevaches
une cinquantaine d'attelages 6-1 1-6 les
petites routes du plateau de millevaches
selon des itinéraires minutieusement
préparé l'hébergement est assuré et soit
dans les auberges soit dans les volets
de randonnée équestre soit seul habitant
chaque semaine pour un prix comprenant
la location de la calèche le cheval et
sa nourriture décalage part du petit
village de la selle en corrèze et
emprunte des routes touristiques aux
confins de la creuse de la corrèze la
haute vienne
c'est la revanche du touriste qui peut
renoncer aux vous encombrer aux
embouteillages aux plages surpeuplées
pour goûter enfin aux charmes
insoupçonnés d'une nature sauvage et
reposante
le retour à la nature n'est ce pas un
peu le rêve de chacun d'entre nous